la plupart des personnes atteintes de
kobe 19 ans ressentent des symptômes
pendant deux à trois semaines
mais pour d'autres le temps de
récupération peut être beaucoup plus
long partout à travers le monde un
nombre grandissant de patients disent
ressentir des séquelles de leur maladie
pendant plusieurs mois
même si le virus a disparu de leur corps
ces personnes sont épuisés ressentent de
la douleur ou des malaises au point où
elles ne sont pas capables de retrouver
une vie normale
on dit que ces personnes sont atteintes
de l'ong qu'ovide ici la recherche
commence à se mettre en place sur le
sujet ça reste un phénomène sur lequel
on connaît bien peu de chose qu'est ce
que la longue queue vide
c'est normal d'être épuisé après une
longue hospitalisation ou après avoir
traversé la phase aiguë d'une maladie
mais le cas des séquelles long terme de
la kfw 19 et particuliers d'abord les
symptômes rapportés sont très variés
pour beaucoup de personnes ça commence
avec un épuisement extrême qui serait
parfois après des activités aussi simple
que monte un escalier d'autres personnes
rapportent des mots tight très important
une capacité de se concentrer un peu
comme si on vivait dans un brouillard
perpétuelle d'autres personnes
rapportent des douleurs aux
articulations ou muscles une difficulté
respiratoire finalement certaines
personnes rapporte même des palpitations
cardiaques une perte longue durée de
certains sens comme l'odorat ou le goût
et les problèmes aux intestins
un autre élément qui distingue les
séquelles long terme de la kfw 19
c'est le nombre de personnes qui sont
touchées des données qui proviennent de
la grande-bretagne et des etats-unis
suggèrent que jusqu'à 10 % des personnes
infectées par le virus le plus souvent
des femmes ressentent encore des
symptômes
un mois après leur infection ces
chiffres vont diminuer avec le temps
mais deux points 5 % des personnes
atteintes vont encore ressentir ces
symptômes après trois mois parfois même
plus on comprend donc avec la quantité
importante de personnes qui ont été
infectées lors de cette pandémie et que
ses symptômes long terme peuvent toucher
des dizaines de
milliers de personnes au canada
seulement quelles sont les causes de
cette complication
ça peut varier d'une personne à l'autre
dans certains cas les chercheurs croient
qu'il s'agit des conséquences d'un
passage aux soins intensifs ou de
l'utilisation d'un respirateur
artificiel
dans d'autres il pourrait s'agir des
séquelles qui ont été laissées après une
très forte réaction inflammatoire que le
système immunitaire aurait déclenché au
moment de l'infection à la coved 19 mai
ces deux possibilités n'explique pas
comment beaucoup de cas de l'ong
qu'ovide surviennent chez des personnes
qui n'ont pas ressenti de 5 tombe au
moment de leur infection
dans ces situations certains chercheurs
croient qu'on pourrait avoir à faire un
virus en dormance à l'intérieur du corps
et que le système immunitaire et réagit
périodiquement dans d'autres on pense
qu'il pourrait avoir eu des dommages aux
organes causés par des micros caillots
sanguins qui se seraient développées
lors de cette maladie
mais malgré toutes ces possibilités
encore aujourd'hui la vaste majorité des
symptômes de la langue qu'ovide reste
inexpliqué une situation qui rappelle
celle d'une autre maladie le syndrome de
la fatigue chronique qu'on appelle aussi
en céphalonie élite myalgique une
maladie au sein tombe très similaires
dont on ne connaît pas les causes mais
qui pourraient survenir avec une
combinaison entre une infection virale
et certains facteurs génétiques
sait-on de la recherche sur la longue
queue vide
puisque la longue co-vedette un
phénomène qu'on connaît depuis quelques
mois à peine et que peu d'études ont été
faites sur le sujet ça reste un des
éléments les moins compris de cette
pandémie
mais depuis quelques mois plusieurs
cliniques qui suivent les patients
atteints de cette complication
on commence à ouvrir leurs portes dans
différentes grandes villes à travers le
pays puisqu'il n'existe pas encore de
traitement contre la langue qu'ovide ces
cliniques peuvent seulement proposer des
pistes de solution au cas par cas ou
aider les patients atteints à apprendre
à mieux gérer leurs symptômes
mais ces cliniques vont aussi permettre
de suivre différents éléments génétiques
physiologique ou immunitaires qui
distingue les patients atteints de la
longue qu'ovide ses études vont
permettre de mieux comprendre l'origine
de cette complication est d'aider à
trouver un traitement qui pourrait
redonner une vie normale aux personnes
atteintes
en attendant les résultats de ces
premières études le meilleur moyen de
réduire les effets de la longue queue
vide c'est de minimiser la propagation
du virus en respectant les mesures
sanitaires
si vous avez d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas à nous les envoyer à
l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran et
nous on va y répondre le plus rapidement
possible